first I'd at Merck become the country's
sole supplier of these measles vaccines
and is is that a problem well is it a
problem depends on who you talk to and
I'll get to that in a sec but Merck
became the sole supplier because the
vaccine market is highly concentrated
it's incredibly expensive to make
vaccines it takes a lot of time to go
through all the testing process at
procedures so Merck was the first to the
table they developed a vaccine got
approval they got government contracts
and they essentially monopolized the
market I talked to Patricia danzon
though at Wharton yesterday she said
that's not surprising she doesn't think
it's a problem Merck is able to offer
this vaccine at a reasonable price and
that tends to discourage competition
because they don't have an incentive as
big of an incentive to enter the market
so right now Merc is the only supplier
of this vaccine in the US and they make
one point four billion dollars on the
measles vaccine every year most of that
is made in the US and you know it's a
drop in the bucket for Merck but a 1
billion dollar market is not a bad thing
to dominate Shelby's statistics show
more and more parents or expressing
concerns about the Merck vaccine about
measles in particular couldn't Merck
perhaps lose dominance here in the
United States well the anti backs are
movement this this trending movement has
been around for a while it's the expert
I talked to yesterday said it's because
measles is spreading that's why these
voices are being amplified so she
doesn't necessarily see the see the
voices and the anti Merck sentiment has
a threat it's been there what could be
threatening to mark is a pending lawsuit
that alleges Merck misled the US
government about the effectiveness of
the particularly in this MMR vaccine the
mumps efficacy so that could take a few
years to figure out it's basically a
thorn in mirc side what really poses a
threat is glaxosmithkline has been they
already have a mm are similar MMR
vaccine it treats me it vaccinates for
measles they've already developed it
it's being used in Europe they've been
testing it in the US and they told me
yesterday in an email that they plan to
apply for a license here in the US I
talked to a CDC a former CDC official
yesterday he said that will definitely
spread out the market share because the
CDC wants multiple suppliers not only
for leverage but because it helps ensure
that you have the supply it's you know
it's safety supply safety so that could
definitely take away their market share
here's flat and you've been talking to
us a past couple of days there was that
outbreak in Arizona near the site of the
Super Bowl I was one in Amish country in
Ohio there's another one at Disneyland
so something that our health public
health officials watching closely Shelby
holiday